i do like your view of the flame with
the bush
and perhaps the sword
as a thing of transformation it's also
it's a transformation that kind of
consumes the thing in the process well
it depends on how much of the thing is
chaff you know this is why you can't
touch the ark of the covenant
for example and this is why people can
have very bad psychedelic trips
it's like if you're 95 dead wood
and you get too close to the flame yeah
the five percent that's left might not
be able to make it
so you think it's all chap but i think
there is some aspect of destruction that
is
that's you know the the old bukowski
line of uh do what you love and let it
kill you right don't you think it that
destruction is part of that's humility
that's humility you bet you bet you bet
it's like
invite in the judgment invite in the
judgment because maybe you can die a
little bit instead of dying completely
yeah you know and that's i think it's
alfred north whitehead
we can let our ideas die instead of us
right we can have these partial
personalities that we can burn off
and we can let them go before they
become tyrannical pharaohs and
everything and we lose everything
and so yeah there's this optimal bite of
death and who knows what it would mean
to optimize that like what if it was
possible that if you died enough all the
time
that you could continue to live
and the thing is we already know that
biologically because
if you don't die properly all the time
well it's cancerous outgrowths and and
like it's a very fine balance between
productivity on the biological front and
the culling of that right
life is a real balance between growth
and death
and so what would happen if you got that
balance right well we kind of know right
because
if you live your life properly so to
speak and you're humble enough to let
your stupidity die before it takes you
out you will live longer that's just a
fact
well but then what's the ultimate
extension of that and the answer is we
don't know we have no idea
you